welcome back to las vegas now august is
national wellness month and joni torres
from the jw marriott spa aqua is here
with some self-care inspiration
so first i want to say congratulations
thank you on the renovation we're so
excited so just kind of take us there
paint the picture for us what happens
when we walk into spa aqua so you're
first greeted by oh you even have a
soothing voice
wow this spa
we have a brand new renovated fitness
center and those include peloton so that
you can have both speak my language and
wellness right but if you want to skip
past the fitness and just go straight to
the wellness we have both our women's
and men's spa and then our co-ed
hydrotherapy lounge oh my gosh all of
them have a steam room sauna hot tub
cold plunge relaxation and then of
course in that hydrotherapy outside
there's those eight circuit pools that
really focus in on different areas
inside of each chamber i'm like wow okay
i'm gonna go ahead and make my
reservation right after this okay so
let's talk about now how you're
celebrating national wellness month and
what people can do oh perfect we are
doing a himalayan stone massaging facial
and we know himalayan stones have 84
vital minerals that help to replenish
your skin it's going to help smooth and
show with the tone and texture and then
of course it's a heated massage
so it's going to help relax those knots
and tension so it's not just about the
relaxation it's getting all of those
benefits and points i know this sounds
so good to all of you guys watching
right now because i am like melting
dying to do this myself um
what's your philosophy at spa aqua
behind wellness because everybody kind
of sees it differently what do you guys
think how do you guys encourage people
we want people to enjoy their own
wellness journey so for everyone that
path is a little different some of us
are looking for more health and some of
us are looking more into wellness and
combining the two right we want you to
feel complete when you leave and so you
create your journey we help you along on
that experience and talking about our
different treatments and services but
really it is your total experience that
we are looking to help okay well since
you guys are helping me create my
experience let's get into the textures
of spa aqua the different treatments we
just introduced a sound of color and so
the sound of color is our manicure and
pedicure treatment and it's a meditative
manicure pedicure treatment so we're
going to just do a few dry brushes so
that you can feel the benefits of that
salt it is 100 organic and it's vegan
what is this doing right now your dry
brush is going to help you exfoliate but
it's also helping with your circulation
that feels amazing do you do that on the
entire body you can do that inside of
our deep relaxed treatment yeah okay
stay over our hydrating mist it's
geranium cedarwood so you can also take
in that smell very hydrating oh my gosh
that smells amazing and as you do the
next one just tell everybody how they
can make a reservation with you all so
you can call us at 702-869-7807
you can also go to spa aqua lv.com and
book your appointments through there
okay okay during this session you also
get to choose your own meditation so you
can look on here when you choose your
polishes and you can choose whichever
meditation works best for you
and that is part of the color
oh that's beautiful oh give me some of
that give me some of that give me some
of that thank you so much this is so
nice spa aqua jw marriott you guys take
advantage it is oh my gosh this is so
great we are open
seven days a week
nine to five each day we're extending
until seven pm there we also have our
barber shop coming as well it's open so
for men and women we'll be right back